wir können hier nicht einfach das
normale nachrichtenprogramm runterspulen
wir können hier nicht einfach business
as usual machen hier um die mittagszeit
um 12 so schön zum mittagessen uns allen
müsste angesichts solcher typen hier
hinter mir der appetit vergangen sein
uns allen ihnen allen zu hause unseren
politikern den beamten beim jugendamt
und so weiter und so weiter
nach dem was wir da am wochenende von
der polizei dank der ermittlungen dort
erfahren haben in münster
theresa hat gesagt der größte
kindesmissbrauchs fall in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik der hier endlich
aufgeflogen ist und wir alle viele viele
viele von uns millionen väter und mütter
in deutschland die können das nicht
einfach hinnehmen das sagen wir so oft
mittlerweile aber dieser fall in münster
der muss jetzt ein einschnitt sein der
muss eine wende sein in unserem umgang
mit dem thema kindesmissbrauch überhaupt
im umgang mit kindern in deutschland wie
wir bisher eltern schützen aber kinder
eben nicht schätzen
lasst uns den fall in münster noch mal
angucken was da passiert ist
das jugendamt kennt diese familie kennt
diesen fall seit über fünf jahren seit
über fünf jahren beschäftigt sich das
jugendamt mit münster mit dieser familie
wo in der gartenlaube jahrelang drei
kinder mindestens drei kinder muss man
ja sagen brutal missbraucht werden immer
und immer wieder das material es wird
gefilmt es wird verkauft es wird daraus
ein geschäft gemacht und das jugendamt
dem feld nichts auf was sind das für die
beamte die diese leute auf bewährung
lassen die diese leute die die kinder
nicht aus der familie heraus nehmen was
sind das für beamte was haben die für
ein gespür für familien wenn sie in
diesem fall in einem so extremen fall
noch nicht einmal einschreiten
aber es geht weiter was sind das für
erzieher in dem fall die diese kinder in
der kita haben den nichts auffällt diese
kinder werden vermutlich
verhaltensauffälligkeiten zeigen aber es
wird nicht gemeldet was sind das für
lehrer die diese kinder kennen und
trotzdem nicht einschreiten und was sind
das auch für nachbarn gegenüber in der
gartenlaube die über jahre nichts
mitbekommen wir sind in corona zeiten so
weit dass wir den missbrauch oder den
verstoß von gegen korona regeln anzeigen
wenn freunde ein bisschen zu viele
freunde im garten grillen aber die
selben nachbarn die dann in der
gartenlaube ihre kinder missbrauchen
über jahre hinweg die werden nicht
angezeigt wir sind immer noch eine
werkschau gesellschaft in deutschland
und wir müssen endlich werden zu einer
hinschaut gesellschaft melden sie ihren
verdacht gehen sie hin und gehen sie das
risiko ein dass einmal die meldung
vielleicht auch zu unrecht passiert sie
müssen die kinder schützen sie müssen
ihren verdacht dem jugendamt ihren
nachbarn den erzieherin den lehrern
melden und sie können die eltern auch
direkt ansprechen wenn sie einen
verdacht haben
dann geht es weiter wenn diese typen
hinter mir wenn die einmal dingfest
gemacht werden dann gibt es keine
bewährung für solche leute es gibt keine
bewährungsstrafen
der konsum von kinderpornografie das ist
eine straftat da sind verbrecher die das
konsumieren und sowieso die das ganze
herstellen es gibt bei diesem thema
keine einzige toleranz